les crs agressés sont originaires de
chalon sur saône
ils sont actuellement en renfort à
grenoble pour des missions de
surveillance et de sécurité
mais hier il était en congé et jouer à
la pétanque dans un petit parc situé
juste en face de la crs 47
de l'autre côté du boulevard les
policiers ont d'abord été invectivé
insulté puis tout a dérapé
selon eux il s'agit clairement d'un
guet-apens compagne est vraiment à
proximité donc d'une cité j'ai quand
même qui est quand même connu reconnu et
malheureusement bien mal connu et le but
voilà c'est d'attirer les collègues
c'est de mettre un feu de poubelle c'est
de mimine agression c'est pour nous nous
a tirés attirer les services de police
les pompiers
un collègue s'est retrouvé au sol et
a été pris à partie par plusieurs
individus
donc qu'ils étaient en moto plusieurs
leur enjoint afin de lui porter secours
et c'est à ce moment là qu'une
quarantaine d'individus se sont jetés
sur l'ensemble des collègues afin de
leur porter des coups bilan quatre
policiers blessés l'un d'eux toujours
hospitalisée souffre notamment de
multiples fractures au visage
il aurait été frappé avec un casque de
moto je dirais que malheureusement sur
tout le territoire ça devient une
habitude puisque on en voit
régulièrement que ce soit des collègues
qui sont en famille en train de se
promener qui se font agresser parce
qu'ils sont reconnus par des individus
c'est des violences que l'on condamne
fortement et on aimerait que y ait une
réponse très forte de la justice parce
que tant que les sont pas condamnés
fortement je pense que ces actes
deviendront banal
malheureusement pas d'interpellation
hier soir l' enquête est en cours